sì assolutamente potremmo prevedere una
collaborazione a lungo termine anche
perché finanziare queste lo nella lobby
come si voleva della collaborazione donò
scusava i furetti problemi da
videochiamata iscriviti al canale per
non perdere neanche un video allora con
questa collaborato ma talmente luigi qui
quindi parla parla parla pure tu si è
invece più ma va
scusate che mi avete abitato all'ultimo
e non ho avuto tempo di prepararmi
scusate lo stato indecente mi senti ma
mi senti bene sì come dicevo prima
analisi i raccordi sembra già abbastanza
completo quindi gli ultimi riscontri
delle al paese prima di originali e
personali definitiva porta di quella
quante volte lo devo dire che quando la
mamma lavora questa asili stare zitte e
quindi per quanto mi riguarda next step
fisserà una colla prossima settimana
animati cioè niente il computer ha
rilevato un virus e io non me lo voglio
prendere commentare i fantastici cuscini
puccioni ma mi vedi mi vedi così mi vedi
si scusatemi sera disconnesso e mi
riassumento gentilmente le ultime due
ore e mezza di videochiamata marino a
quel petico privato perché dicono che
giunchi ruby d'identità ciao a tutti
scusate ma oggi sono davvero
impresentabile quindi ho messo questo
filtro
è carino mamma non ti vedo mamma sta
inquadrando soffitto mancino questa
videocamera no ma in che senso non li
vedi scusami io ti vedo
per quanto riguarda la controparte
abbiamo novità
valerio valerio mi mi senti ma credo che
abbia il ri profondo disattivato valerio
non ti sentiamo valerio se gentilmente
attivi microfono knox non capisce va
bene niente andiamo avanti
io ho già inviato e le mail a tutti
quanti anche a francesco quindi non ci
dovrebbero essere problemi ma ho capito
che ti bloccata l'immagine però adesso
basta ridere se parlo così mi senti
meglio
clicca il bottone allora il bottone in
basso a destra c'è un rotondino con una
specie di forma allungata ecco quello è
un microfono se tu lo clicchi ok io ti
posso sentire se non per sette ragazzi
alle ragazze tutte grazie a questo punto
ci aggiorniamo domani con il rapper
definitivo ok ciao a tutti ciao ciao
grazie grazie
ma si chiede style è creata di merda con
il bottone rosso a ok non avete sentito
vero senti un po ma questa videochiamata
quanto costa si scusate vado a prendere
dei documenti di lama vi ascolto quindi
continuate pure a parlare anche se mi
alzo insomma ascolto perfettamente
arrivo subito
[Musica]
ciao
[Applauso]
e così aquilano aumentassimo il
fatturato di citi vercesi quindi appare
soltanto le cuffie le clip le cure non
mi sento molto male c'è se benissimo
sono io che ti sento male quindi sentore
non sento nessuno e allora 20 per favore
le cooper che c'è proprio guarda sento
proprio le dico che ti senti ma non ci
sono problemi
smetti queste di cuffie sia adesso forse
non mi sento benissimo